just when you think america has reached
the maximum level of queerness not just
a little light in the loafers but full
on queerer than a three dollar bill just
when you think things cannot get any
queerer
the speaker of the house of
representatives appears on a drag queen
tv show to declare that transvestitism
is what america is all about
please give a warm drag race welcome to
the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
welcome back
my honor to be here
to say to all of you how proud we all
are of you
thank you for the joy and beauty you
bring to the world ah your freedom of
expression of yourselves in drag is what
america is all about i say that all the
time to my friends in drag
[Laughter]
that's what america is all about quote
our constitution was built for moral and
religious people
and more than that
it's built for dudes to strap on
stilettos and strut around like cartoon
caricatures of a prostitute it is wholly
inadequate to the government of any
other so said john adams did he i don't
i don't think so it is
increasingly however the view held by
our elite institutions which are
uniformly promoting transvestitism
and transgenderism and transsexualism
including among children and the voices
calling for this child abuse and this
perversion and this madness
are not just on the radical left the
situation has gotten so bad in this
country
even the largest conservative cable news
channel has joined the chorus not just
waving the rainbow flag but even
encouraging parents to trans their kids
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on fridays from joseph h
who says donuts and other yummy snacks
at the child drag workshop all that's
missing is the puppy in the van
time to start a group and call it d.a.d
dads against drag that's probably a good
idea if we still had a robust sense of
masculinity and fatherhood in this
country i don't think that you would
have people like a cartoon like a
caricature it's the same thing as the
drag issue
and in this case even more so the drag
workshops for kids it's like a
caricature of some sexual predator come
here kids oh yes we've got candies and
goodies yeah just go into that extremely
creepy looking van over there yeah
that's right we've got all sorts of
wonderful snacks now put on your
stilettos and strut around not a good
idea probably better you know if you're
if you're finding that your legs have
strained from those stilettos it's good
to kick back a little bit relax you've
got to do it on an all-form sofa right
now go to
allform.com you know how much i love my
helix bed i have invited you into my
boudoir to just
hear about the wonderful aspects of my
helix mattress well helix has left the
bedroom they are now making sofas
they've got a new company called all
form they are making the coolest sofas
ever what makes them so cool is that you
can pick pretty much everything you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you can pick the
fabric the sofa color the color of the
legs the size the shape you can make
sure that it is perfect for you and your
home they've got armchairs they've got
love seats really cool thing is
let's say you're you're in a small
apartment right now maybe you're going
to move into a house you can add on to
your all-form sofa so that it grows as
you grow you get 100 days to decide if
you want to keep it but you're gonna
love it so it won't matter uh if you
don't love it they will pick it up give
you a full refund they've got a forever
warranty literally forever to find your
perfect sofa go to allform.com knowles
all form is offering 20 off all orders
at allforum.com
knowles
i had to blink on friday i had to clear
my eyes and shake my head and blink
because i know it's june and in june
everything goes super gay and it doesn't
just go gay gay is now bourgeois gay is
now old-fashioned and traditional now it
goes trans and it doesn't just go trans
for the adults it goes trans for the
kids so i know that i expect that from
all the left-wing news outlets which is
to say almost all the news outlets i
expect this from all the left-wing
corporations which is to say almost all
the corporations i expect this certainly
from all the left-wing tv channels which
is to say most of the tv channels
but i saw
a segment
being run
not just on the topic of transgenderism
not just on the topic of transgendering
the kids but act actively promoting
transing the kids and i saw this segment
not on msnbc
and not on cnn
i saw it on fox news
14 year old ryland whittington is a
typical southern california teenager
and the whittingtons along with mom
hillary dad jeff and sister brinley are
a typical family the only difference
though in ryland's eyes is what this
family can mean to the tens of thousands
of kids under 18 who identify as
transgender we put our story out there
so people can
see that like there's another family out
there that
is
going through what we're going through
or there's another family who's proud of
who they are before rylan could even
speak he managed to tell his parents
that he is a boy i could just see it it
wasn't him trying to be
a brat it was like painful it was truly
painful for him to have to wear feminine
clothing and and for us constantly
telling him that you're a girl and
unlike some trans kids when rylan came
out at age five a few years later he had
the full support of his parents i'm just
here to make the ride smoother for
others what extraordinary courage
displayed by ryland his sister brinley
father jeff and mom hillary i want to
thank the whittington family for
speaking to us it's not easy
particularly at a time when when
transgender issues have been politicized
people are afraid of what they do not
understand this family hopes their story
will lead to more understanding more
acceptance and ultimately more love
and ultimately
more love
that's the last word there
this is not just covering
this
this is not just
well look at this weird story it would
be abusive enough to run a big segment
go out film this family and this poor
little girl where they're obviously
screwing up this poor girl on all sorts
of hormones and that's why her voice is
so much deeper
that that would be bad enough
but this
this creep reporter on fox news is
promoting it
and by the way the clip goes on
three minutes longer it gets worse and
worse we don't have time to cover the
whole thing on the show this is a
full-throated endorsement
on the news side of fox news of
transgendering the kids
i
i refrain from friendly fire on the
right even among
right-wing personalities and politicians
and organizations that i don't even like
all that much i refrain from friendly
fire generally i try to abide by ronald
reagan's 11th commandment thou shalt not
speak ill of a fellow republican
i cannot think of anything more evil
that fox news could do than endorse
transing kids then encourage parents to
trans their kids and in the other parts
of that segment they say yeah you know
we're using statistics from the trevor
project which is a radical pro lgbt
organization and the statistics say if
you don't trans your little kids they're
going to kill themselves so what do you
want do you want it they actually use
this line they say would you rather have
a dead daughter or a living son or
really it's just a girl who's a daughter
who's pretending to be a boy
what do you want you want to kill your
kid well if you don't want to kill your
kid give a ton of money to
pharmaceutical psychos to pump your kid
full of hormones so that you can
permanently screw up their body and
probably give them osteoporosis or
something make them sterile forever when
they come to regret this in ten years
you're gonna have destroyed their lives
but if you don't do it now you're gonna
kill your kids that's the kind of stuff
that's being promoted on fox news
channel
good grief what has happened
i can't i can't figure it out i
i can't i can't refrain from criticizing
them here i have
i've appeared on fox news about a
bazillion times
i've i've promoted multiple books on fox
news went back last year tucker helped
me promote my book speechless
i wish that the fox news executives had
had read that book i wish they had
listened to some of their own
programming this is insane it's very
difficult for me i was trying to make a
joke about what's going to happen next
at fox news
what are they going to promote next
blank you know they're promoting this so
i was trying to think of some hyperbolic
satirical thing i could say what what's
the even crazier thing that they could
promote there's nothing crazier they've
reached it that's the bottom of the
slippery slope
maybe bestiality i'm not i don't think
that's even worse we're talking about
mutilating the genitals of little kids
and if you don't do it you're a terrible
parent they say
this is
it shows you how far america has fallen
it it actually gives some credence to
what nancy pelosi was saying
transvestitism is what america is all
about maybe it is i don't think it's
what ordinary americans are about i
don't think it's what the majority of
the american people are about
but i do think
that it might be what every single one
of our institutions is about including
the quote-unquote conservative ones
including the quote-unquote right-wing
ones there's there's a uniform agreement
now
not just on
the rainbow not just on homosexuality
not just on transgenderism on transing
the freaking little kids
wasn't just
fox news promoting this stuff
you're seeing this now
somehow this is more disgusting it's
probably less
it's less evil but it's definitely more
disgusting there was an ad that came out
from postmates which is a food delivery
service
on
listen i'm no expert in in the nuances
of this particular
sexual ideology but it was
it was this sort of
stuff you should
eat
from postmates if you want to engage in
certain activities
what are you eating this pride
well if you're a top it seems like you
can eat whatever you want
[Music]
but if you're a bottom you're expected
to starve
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
we teamed up with dr evan goldstein from
bespoke surgical to bring you a menu of
bottom friendly foods backed by science
insoluble fiber won't help you feel cute
so avoid things like whole grains sweet
bran cauliflower potatoes legumes
hold up are you just fully diving into
those beans
the problem with these foods is they
don't dissolve in water which could
cause a traffic jam in your digestive
system making a mess of your evening
there's no right or wrong way to bottom
but if you're planning on getting peachy
this pride the bottom friendly menu on
postmates has the kinds of foods that
could keep you feeling good are you
organic
they put the avocado in an s m
leather
studs
metal
that's so gross and i i realized why
they're doing it i couldn't figure out
what this is the most disgusting thing
i've ever seen in any commercial why and
they're doing it because for for years
corporations have been attacked even by
the left-wing lgbt activists they say
you only you just put your logo in a
rainbow for pride you don't really care
you just you it's just you're pandering
but you don't really change anything and
so i know there were there was a board
meeting there was some kind of executive
meeting at postmates and they said you
know we got to really prove it to him
this year we are going to go into the
most absolutely disgusting granular
detail on on lgbt relations and and
we're going to include avocados and
peaches and all sorts of stuff to
digestive tracts and we are we're
committed this year please maybe go back
to the logo i think that we were fine
with the logo in washington dc
there's a big pride parade there are
pride parades
everywhere throughout the entire country
throughout the entire
world it's throughout it's throughout
the western world at this point
during one of these pride parades
there was a man
uh running down the street
he appears to have had
breast implants or some kind of
chemically induced breasts or something
and he ends up twerking on a policeman
so you can see him there
he's strutting in front of a sign that
says european union for lgbt plus rice
heat
he appears to have something like
breasts or any
areas twerking on a cop
in there
[Applause]
there's someone waving the
european flag oh and the people waving
the european flag seem to be very young
there are plenty of kids there out in
the crowd
and the man with the breasts
twerking on the cop and the cop just
runs away
in a more sane age the cop would
put this guy in cuffs and take him
either to jail or or more likely a
lunatic asylum and say something's going
wrong in your life buddy and we got to
figure it out so that you don't do stuff
like this but the guy in the in the
street with the
some kind of augmented breasts
had demon horns on like little devil
horns and you you do notice this a lot
there's a lot of overlap here between
the radical sexual revolutionary stuff
and demonic imagery sinful imagery
satanic imagery and i imagine that the
activists on the the sexual revolution
side we'll just write this off and say
oh we're just being provocative oh it's
not we don't really believe in the devil
oh we don't really but i don't how come
this this imagery keeps cropping up all
the time
and the tw and it's so brazen now and
it's so obscene i
if obscenity laws have any meaning
whatsoever and we still have obscenity
laws on the books if they have any
meaning whatsoever
a demon horn wearing dude with breasts
wearing a thong jiggling on a police
officer in front of kids i think has to
count
right and if that doesn't count
we don't we don't effectively have
obscenity laws anywhere
in this country
or throughout the western world
in idaho there was a pride parade
this took place in coridalin
idaho
police arrested 31 members of a group
called patriot front
this group the 31 people in patriot
front were found in a u-haul vehicle
near the pride parade and they were just
there in their vehicle but the cops said
it is clear to us based on the gear that
the individuals had with them the stuff
they had in their possession the u-haul
with them along with the paperwork that
was seized from them that they came to
riot downtown
so notice here
this group patriot front fed front i
don't know i've i haven't really heard
very much about this group and whenever
i hear about it
it's in this way that seems to be
actively promoted by the establishment
media and i'm sort of skeptical that the
group even exists beyond something
thought up in langley or
quantico but regardless let's say it is
real this far-right radical group they
were arrested
for
potentially planning
to riot
blm very often doesn't get arrested for
actually rioting and burning things down
and killing people but this far right
group
gets arrested for potentially planning
to riot
so for a potential crime
at a pride parade
where real crimes are taking place
at the very least the crime of obscenity
at the very least the crime of public
disturbance at the very least the crime
of indecent exposure and indecent
exposure toward kids there are kids at
all of these pride parades
and yet the cops never arrest the
weirdos like the
like the demon horn wearing guy with his
breasts hanging out jiggling on a cop in
front of kids they never arrest those
guys for committing actual crimes but
then they rush in we got gotta send in
the swat team we gotta send in the the
fbi to go arrest
this
minor right-wing group
that may or may not be real in the first
place for potentially i'm not defending
this group if it's real or not patriot
front fin arrest them if you want if
they've committed a crime
but how come
we focus all
of the resources in law enforcement on
punishing right-wing people for crimes
that they may be committed maybe didn't
commit maybe plan to commit maybe don't
but we don't ever punish
leftists who are actually committing
crimes
in the same place at the same time doing
the same thing
doesn't make sense seems to me we should
focus more of our resources on arresting
the groomers
on arresting the weirdos the the people
frankly would be for their own good i
don't think the guy in the in the demon
horns with the boobs hanging out i don't
think that guy is living his best life i
don't think he's got it all together i
don't think he's flourishing okay
but we have said no that is flourishing
that's the that's what we should all
want fox freaking news is saying if your
kid
if your kid is two years old and can't
even speak yet
we've got it you've got to trans your
kid
and in that fox segment by the way the
mother would you believe it the mother
has a book deal talking about all this
this creepy mother who says oh yes
before my daughter could speak before my
i'm sorry before my son could speak he
told me that he is totally a boy and not
a girl which she obviously is
even fox news promoting that stuff
all of that is totally fine but
we've got to focus all of our attention
on the threat from the far right radical
insurrectionists goodness gracious if we
don't stop them a midwestern dad might
drink a coors light in the capital
rotunda could you imagine
it brings me back to this question is
pelosi right
is pelosi right when she says
transvestitism is what america is all
about
no
not if you ask the majority of americans
not if you ask the founding fathers
they'd be rolling over in their graves
but there is something
weird about america with this issue
the western world broadly kind but it's
america in particular has this you
remember the french
a few months ago uh macron said we don't
want wokeness wokeness is very bad it's
a cultural export from america and it's
poisoning everything we don't want it we
don't do wokeness in in france which is
one of the most left-wing places in the
western world but they said we don't
want that so what is it about america i
think it's that
in america
there is this idea
that you can be whatever you want to be
in america it doesn't matter how you're
born what you look like what your skills
are even you every every child born in
america can be the president of the
united states
any child if he really puts his mind to
it can be an astronaut any you can be
anything and there's something
nice about this idea in america
but
it isn't true
there's a lot of freedom in america
there's a lot of freedom of mobility
there's so much opportunity go west
young man go strike your fortune there
is
there is some truth to the american
dream
but that's not absolute you can't do
whatever you want to do i will never be
a basketball player i never could have
been a basketball player i was born
with certain limitations
okay when you are a child of the mezzo
giorno of southern italy okay and you're
not six foot seven and you're not from
the most athletic race of people in the
world then you're just not i'm never
going to play in the nba that was a
limit that i had okay but i've got other
limits beyond that
i've got limits of nature of biology i'm
never going to be a girl i'm never going
to be a woman
i can i can really want to be a woman
but i i can't be
there are natural limits here the reason
that
that america worked for so long
is because we had this really
inspirational idea of you can do
pretty much whatever you want to do but
we had a culture a tradition of limits
and we had a religion
christianity that told us that we have
responsibilities that we have a moral
order that we have to respect we have
natural boundaries we have to respect
and we've got to
to give ourselves over to god's will and
cooperate with his grace
as america has become
less christian still religious but it's
less christian to be a much more
leftist transgenderist
individualist whatever
all of those limits are gone and it's
just like what you can have beautiful
poetry when you respect a few simple
boundaries meter rhyme
really basic stuff
when you get rid of those boundaries you
get slam poetry which is the death of
art it's the worst thing ever that's
that's where we are i think this this
might be
the issue we need to recognize that
nancy pelosi's idea that the great thing
about america is is
dancing around in drag the great thing
about america is the freedom quote
unquote to dance around like a
transvestite
no that isn't it we know that that's not
it we know that's not what the founding
fathers thought we know that that's not
what anybody thought in this country
until five minutes ago for goodness
sakes transvestitism was illegal in much
of america for much of the 19th century
and parts of the 20th century including
san francisco
so we know that's not what america is
about if your idea of america is that
that's what america is about then your
idea is wrong we need to go back to
history to our tradition to our actual
culture and say where did we go wrong
where when you're twerking on the cops
and grooming and transiting the kids
something has gone wrong speaking of
your kids you're going to want to make
sure they're taken care of someday when
you are gone that's why you got to check
out epic will right now go to
epicwill.com use promo code knowles life
comes at you fast it can leave you even
faster i don't want to be too blunt
about it but that's the way it is you
picture yourself living to a ripe old
age it doesn't always work out that way
if it doesn't you are going to want to
have a plan in place otherwise the state
the corrupt ruling class that you do not
like the people who are trying to
indoctrinate your kids and take your
guns and steal all your rights they are
going to step in and take control of
everything all your assets your money
your property your children they're
going to determine what sort of legacy
you leave behind
don't let that happen don't let these
weirdos decide what happens to your kids
okay don't let them decide who gets your
gold or your crypto or your comic book
collection instead take five minutes set
up a will through epic will starting at
just 119 bucks look even i i hadn't
updated my will in forever until very
very recently so i get it people put it
off don't put it off any longer epic
will is protecting a lot of us here at
the daily wire let them protect you too
go to epicwhill.com
use code knowles you'll get 10
off on epic will's complete will package
takes only five minutes to set up
we're so appreciative to epic will for
taking care of us let him take care of
you epicwheel.com promo code knowles do
something for you and your family today
the hits just keep on coming here at the
daily wire so you know what is a woman
was a smashing success thank you so much
for everyone who went out and watched
that movie we've got a new movie coming
out with gina carano that is terror on
the prairie i'm very excited for this i
am going down to see it tonight i'm
seeing a special sneak exclusive
premiere but the public premiere is
tomorrow so i'll tell you what i think
if it's no good i'll tell you don't
worry about it i've heard this movie is
phenomenal it's got gina it's got nick
seriously it's just uh it's going to be
great june 14th is when the daily wire
premieres this great new film terror on
the prairie go to dailywire.com gina
tune in tomorrow at 8 30 eastern for the
pre-show 9 pm eastern for the world
premiere of the film stick around for a
q a following the movie head on over to
dailywire.com gina now
we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show
i mentioned it a little bit earlier
there is this strange
thing about pride which is that there's
a lot of
satanic imagery
it just keeps popping up little devil
horns and
tridents and
you know allusions to sin and evil and
transgression and it's just weird demons
you notice the drag queens
often look like demons especially at the
drag queen story hour what's that about
what is that well in
core deli in idaho and the pride in the
park event which is billed as family
friendly
they're going to feature the satanic
temple
the satanic temple is going to be there
along with performances by drag queens
and other progressive institutions
if you are a christian if you are a
practicing jew if you're a practicing
muslim this will not surprise you you
say yeah of course
and you've got these people who are
violating the moral order and and
dancing around like chicks in front of
children and sexualizing them yeah no no
surprise that there's going to be
satanic imagery around that no but if
you're if you're agnostic if you're a
atheist if you're a secularist
you might be a little confused by this
say what does one have to do with the
other
drag queens that's just about pursuing
your own sexual identity and being true
to your authentic self even though that
authentic self has nothing to do with
your actual body
or nature but you know it's somehow it's
your authentic self and so why on earth
would that have anything to do with the
devil okay
regardless of one's confusion here can
we all agree
can we please all agree
to keep the satanists out of it get this
the satanists recently have been going
to public schools they went to
elementary schools and holding after
elementary school extracurricular
activities for kids can we all agree
just like we can all agree unless you're
an executive at fox news that
but if you're a normal ordinary person
we all agree it's not good to trans the
kids don't don't mess up a
five-year-old's genitals and permanently
mutilate their bodies right we all agree
on that can we all agree
keep the satanists
away from the kids and out of the public
square i'm comfortable agreeing with
that
some people might not be though because
they say well that's a violation of the
separation of church and state michael
if you think that the christians ought
to have a place in the public square
which increasingly they don't by the way
according to our secular enlightened
rulers but if you think the christians
ought to have a place in the public
square if you think the jews or the
muslims ought to have a place in the
public square
surely we have to allow the satanists to
that's that's what freedom of religion
means in america that's what america is
all about is allowing baphomet
worshipers to to try to spread their
satanic message to the masses right is
that what it's about
i don't know if you if you asked george
washington or john adams or thomas
jefferson even he was probably the most
lib among the founders if you said hey
guys
you just created this country
codified in these founding documents
would you say america's all about
letting satanists prey on the people
they would laugh at you
they would laugh at you if they weren't
tar and feathering you okay obviously
that's not what america is all about but
then how do we get around it
because we have this idea of freedom of
religion in america so how do you get
around booting the satanists out
i think that the satanist should be
completely ostracized from society we
have groups that are completely
ostracized from society if
at this pride parade
the ku klux klan decided they wanted to
host a booth
do you think they would be permitted to
do that
do you do you really believe that the
organizers of the pride parade would
allow the ku klux klan to have a booth
there
i don't think so do you think the
government would allow the ku klux klan
to have a booth there let's say the
government were running this parade they
actually might be
would the government allow the ku klux
klan to be there and they set up their
little booth and they've got all their
hoods and they got a burning cross next
to them and they're just signing people
up to join the clan do you think that
that would be permitted
of course not
no one no one would permit that anywhere
in america
satanists are at least as bad as the
clan
right
people who worship
the devil
are at least as bad
as people who
hate other people because of their race
or whatever and who intimidate other
people and scare that
people who
commit evil acts
are bad enough
but people who literally worship evil or
are at least that bad right i suspect
they're much worse so if we're going to
ostracize the clan
why wouldn't we ostracize the satanists
because we've we've fallen for this trap
of the libs that they convinced us in
the middle of the 20th century when all
of this changed that actually you know
the true meaning the true meaning of
america the true what we're really all
about in the constitution is supporting
uh drag queens and satanism and
grooming the kids and upending all of
our institutions that's the true meaning
of america of course it's not it was a
lie and the conservatives just fell for
it which is too bad you want to talk
about an inversion of rights
look up at america's hat right now
justin
castro just justin castro trudeau up in
canada
has just declared
that while maybe you can still keep some
of your guns in canada you cannot use
the guns
for self-defense there are debates and
we have a culture where the difference
is guns can be used for hunting or for
sport shooting in canada and there's
lots of gun owners and they're mostly
lost respecting and law abiding
but you can't use a gun for
self-protection in canada that's not a
right that you have in the constitution
or anywhere else if you try and buy a
gun and say it's for self-protection no
you don't get that you get it for
hunting you can get it for sport
shooting take it to the range no problem
as long as you go through our rigorous
background checks but there's a
difference around the culture and one of
the things that we're seeing with the
debate in the states is you get more and
more of the american style you know
right to carry self-defense arguments
filtering up through through the uh you
know the usual more right-wing
communications channels
he's talking about us by the way
trudeau is blaming us for radicalizing
the canadians to believe they have a
right to self-defense
they don't have a right to self-defense
you only have a right to go hunting
maybe with your guns
and as usual trudeau gets this exactly
backwards
no one has a
natural right to go hunting you don't
that's not what the right to guns has
ever been about
you do not have a right to go shooting
clays at the range as he suggests that
you do
the only reason that you have a right
to arm yourself
is for self-defense
friends of mine liberal relatives and
friends of mine will say michael look
i'm okay with some guns but only guns
for hunting you don't need an ar-15 to
go hunting
first of all you actually can hunt some
animals with an ar-15 but second of all
the second amendment is not for hunting
it is for self-protection protecting say
your home from a burglar
protecting yourself and your family if
you're attacked on the street
and ultimately protecting yourself
from
even a state actor
that is tyrannical and in if you if you
are justified in protecting yourself in
order to to fulfill that
that's why the second amendment
recognizes the right inherited from the
british
a right that isn't just inherited from
the british it goes all the way back to
the natural law we have a natural right
to protect ourselves
and that's the right
that trudeau is attacking
saying no no no no
it's not just an attack on gun ownership
he's he's okay with some guns he's
saying no it's all right you can keep
some of your guns he's attacking the
natural law which is what this is all
about this is what all these people keep
attacking
it's not even that they're attacking
specific cultural institutions or civil
rights they're really attacking the
natural law and natural reality and the
difference between boys and girls
and the fact that babies are babies and
the fact that we have and we can know
through our reason we know that we have
a right to protect ourselves from
weirdos like justin trudeau
you have to protect yourself
it's like it would be like saying look
here in canada
we we are fine with you possessing pipe
cleaners you can you know those little
fuzzy little pipe cleaners you you're
we're fine but you can only use that for
kindergarten arts and crafts projects
you cannot use that to clean a pipe
no no that that's very you have no right
to use the pipe cleaner to clean a pipe
but you can use it to decorate little
boxes when you when you do arts and
crafts with your kids no no
cleaning a pipe is what a pipe cleaner
is for
self-defense is what a gun
is for
you have to protect yourself think about
the kavanaugh's fortunately
the supreme court justices have some
protection now given to them by the
state brett kavanaugh had a couple u.s
marshals sitting outside his house
that's how they were able to stop the
guy who showed up to kill him in his
home in his bed next to his wife with
his daughters down the hallway
the guy who came all the way from
california because he was upset that
kavanaugh is a conservative judge who's
going to rule on cases he doesn't like
luckily he was able to be protected
what about you and me what about all the
rest of us what about people who don't
have 24 7 security
you need to have a gun to protect
yourself do you know
how the liberal networks covered the
assassination attempt on brett kavanaugh
you know
cable tv i don't have cable anymore i
don't watch this stuff i only ever find
this stuff when i'm looking on twitter
and the clips go around
even the fox news club i wasn't watching
fox news i just saw the clip going
around so few people texted it to me
actually and
they wanted me to tweet it out
because you know a lot of conservatives
rely on
fox news to be able to go and promote
their own stuff that's why there's been
some reticence on the conservative right
to criticize fox news here but you got
to do it you got to call a spay to spade
and so a number of people are doing that
now
but
do you know how the other shows covered
this stuff abc cbs nbc cnn on the sunday
shows the big sunday show to recap the
week
abc this week zero mentions of the
attempted kavanaugh assassination
nbc meet the press zero mentions of the
attempted kavanaugh assassination
cbs
face the nation zero mentions of the
attempted kavanaugh assassination cnn
zero zero mentions on the sunday show of
zero nothing they completely block it
out
you're going to hear wall-to-wall
coverage of the january january 6th
hearing the worst day in american
history
not even the worst insurrection of that
year but no the worst day ever you're
gonna hear that wall-to-wall you're
gonna hear about this fake group i'm
sorry this potentially real group
patriot front
then the the attack that they almost
they almost did but they were foiled by
our intrepid federales you're going to
hear a lot about that
you will not hear about the attempted
pretty near assassination of a supreme
court justice by a leftist lunatic the
establishment papers do you know how
they covered it
not very well
this is a hat tip here to steve guest
who who put side by side the various
newspapers here
there was no mention
of the assassination attempt on
kavanaugh on the front pages of the
chicago tribune or usa today not even a
mention not even a little tiny thing in
the corner hey a leftist guy came pretty
close to assassinating supreme court
justice brett kavanaugh after the white
house had encouraged illegal protests
outside of the justice's house no no
mention there and then the new york
times and the la times
they did put it on the page
but it wasn't the top headline as it
should have been they put a little tiny
bit down in the corner tiny little small
font oh yeah by the way
by the way there was this little attempt
it's no big deal nothing to see here
move along move along talk about january
6th
january 6th so
so
so
silly and then they doubled down on the
issue because there's the attack
first you had the leak of the supreme
court opinion
unprecedented in how this was done for
this major opinion
this was leaked then you had a left-wing
group
dox the justices and call for people to
protest outside of the justice's house
which is illegal according to federal
law then the left-wingers came out there
and screamed and yelled outside the
justice's house alito had to be moved
into protection the other justices
stayed at their homes and the white
house was asked about this they say hey
what do you think about these illegal
protests outside the house they say yeah
no big deal whatever
yeah it's peaceful so far it's cool
yeah we don't we don't have an official
position on where people should protest
wink
yeah no we that's fine we like this in
civil engagement even outside their
homes
right and then what happens some wacko
encouraged by them decides to try to
kill kavanaugh they rush that under the
rug and then aoc
even after the attempt on kavanaugh's
life
goes on social media and brags about how
she voted against increasing security
for the justices
now i wake up this morning and i start
to hear murmurs that there's going to be
an attempt to pass the supreme court
supplemental protection bill
the day after gun safety legislation for
schools and kids and people uh uh is
stalled
oh so we can pass protections for us
and and here easily right but we can't
pass protections for everyday people i
think
not i think not a aoc seems to think
that she is a member of the supreme
court which mercifully she is not yet
she is a member of congress
she says well look the republicans won't
vote to give me my radical gun control
bills which have very little to do with
protecting schools because don't forget
the republicans agreed to protect
schools they said look democrats and
republicans we can come together
and at least agree
lock the doors at schools we can at
least agree have an armed guard at the
schools at least one maybe two we get
really basic stuff we're not going to
agree on gun control legislation even
left-wing outlets like the washington
post admit that gun control legislation
that has been
proposed in recent years would not have
stopped recent mass shootings so look
that's very contentious you guys are
just using this you're exploiting the
school shooting to try to push the same
old laws that you've been pushing for 50
years so let's table that for a second
we can agree on protecting schools right
the democrats say no and they say okay
well look the people are trying to
murder the supreme court justices can't
we at least agree to put a couple more
security guards by their house and what
does aoc she says no
she says no
because
the
the attempt on kavanaugh's life was not
a fluke it was not
an unfortunate unforeseen consequence of
what the democrats have been calling for
it was the point the democrats have been
threatening these judges kavanaugh in
particular don't forget chuck schumer
goes out there he says we're going to
unleash the whirlwind brett kavanaugh
we're coming for you brett kavanaugh
they've been saying this for years now
and they've really ramped it up in
recent weeks so is it any surprise that
when they someone tries to kill
kavanaugh they say yeah we're not giving
you any more security of course not that
was the point the whole
time
speaking of
intellectually morally emotionally
stunted women
there's a sixth grade teacher who just
took
to tick-tock so i think it was tick tock
maybe it was facebook maybe it was
instagram i don't know it was at least
provided to us by libs of tick tock some
one of the greatest journalists of our
age libs of tick tock and this sixth
grade teacher was crying was crying on
the video because she said that her
sixth grade students
made her feel so safe when she came out
to them
as queer
i've been wanting to do this for the
past two years
sorry i'm like so emotional
um and i just haven't had the courage to
do it
out of fear of just judgment mostly from
their parents
but
i had these kids in fourth grade and
now i have them in six and i'm sending
them to middle school and i love these
kids so much and i trust them and they
make me feel safe and
i know they love me and
just felt right and i i did it and
it was so beautiful
[Music]
they had so many questions which i loved
they wanted to learn and they wanted to
learn about me and
they were so eager and
a few of them clapped which was
so precious
the 11 year olds clapped for me when i
told them about my sexual desires and
how my sexual desires are a little
different than what are considered
normal and they just these 11 year old
little tiny children not even teenagers
yet they just make me feel so safe and
i'm sorry if i'm crying it's just i
really
need the affirmation the sexual
affirmation of 11 year olds
hi i'm a sixth grade teacher
mike cernovich made a really great point
on this video in particular
he pointed out it's it's not even that
they're all pedos i've said this for for
a while i don't think
that these teachers are all pedophiles
they are groomers but they're not i
don't think it's because they want to
do weird stuff well they do want to do
weird stuff kids i don't think it's that
they want a sexual relationship with
kids i think it's that
they are
very stunted people who have never grown
up who have never been educated who have
never matured
and so they're just kids themselves
that woman should not be teaching a
classroom not only because she's
doesn't seem particularly well balanced
or well grounded but she she isn't
mature
if you're a teacher
you should not be relying
on your 11 year old students for
affirmation
okay you shouldn't be crying and sobbing
and confiding in them about your sex
life
that's
it's really weird and creepy and it's
not good for them but it's sad for you
and you you need to figure something out
and you need to grow up a little bit
before you can hold any job really but
certainly before you can be expected to
educate children you can't you can't
educate children if you are still a
child
yourself
speaking of these maturity issues you're
gonna be shocked to hear this story
totally she's not exact exactly a man
bites dog story this is from the
national pulse
a former head of
one a foundation that runs a drag queen
story hour program this guy brett blum
he was just arrested for kitty porn
can you believe that this guy who ran an
organization that sends perverts into
libraries and classrooms to twerk for
little kids
programs by the way drag queen story
hour that have
not infrequently had sexual offenders go
in people who had already committed sex
crimes with kids go in and participate
in this program turns out that guy had
child pornography can you imagine isn't
that so shocking he he was the head of
the cream city lgbtq plus foundation
that runs the drag queen story hour
program
he's 38 years old he was taken into
custody quote following an investigation
into multiple uploads of child
pornography through the kick messaging
application account
kick is that's another one there's
there's too many social media accounts
there's there's tick tock instagram
facebook kick what is kick are we gonna
have kicks of tick tock no libs of kick
i don't know
if this is what kik is being used for i
definitely don't want libs of cake uh he
he was he uploaded these a couple years
ago and he just got arrested
there is a weird overlap here
okay i'm not saying that everyone who is
promoting drag queen story hour is a
pedo i don't think that they are
i'm not saying that everyone who is
promoting these bizarre pride parades
where people in chaps with their
sort of
cosmetically altered appendages hanging
out jiggling in front of kids i'm not
even saying that they're all pedos
probably probably some of them are but
i'm not saying that they all are but
there is a weird overlap
there is just something
intrinsically disordered
about
demanding that we sexualize kids and we
talk
about sex to kids and that we introduce
kids to sexual concepts and that we
that we
promote extremely graphic sexual
ideologies among kids and that we even
mutilate the sexual organs of kids
there's something really really messed
up about that and the whole not the
whole country has gone i think most of
the country is against this
but every elite institution has fallen
under its way every single one
schools in the government and the the
online food ordering companies and the
news media
and the quote-unquote conservative news
media it's all fallen under this way
there are certain reasons for this there
are actually some financial reasons for
this as well in the way that
corporations are structured maybe we'll
get into that later this week but
there's there is just a cultural mania
that has taken root
among the people who run our country and
look i i trust in the american people to
have common sense and i think we still
do have common sense but elites can do a
lot of damage even if the elites are a
minority even if the elites in terms of
their actual numbers are relatively
small people who control the
institutions can do a whole lot of
damage
and we have gotten
as far down the slippery slope as i
could possibly imagine if the american
people do not push back now i can't i
can't think of anything worse
that this could fall to
it will but i can't think of anything
where this is the moment
to push back i'm michael knowles this
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show fox news
features an entire segment praising a
family that transitioned a small girl
into a small boy the democratic party
tries to figure out how to dump joe
biden on the side of the road and senate
republicans sign on to a gun control
agenda that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen